all right welcome to scene
at the academy here uh today uh we're
going to examine uh three different
scenes from a terrific film here from
writer director sophia coppola on the
rocks so happy to have her here
to explain all of this for us and
welcome sophia
thank you thanks for having me
absolutely i
love this movie uh i reviewed it i did
everything with it it's just a charming
film
in so many ways before we talk about the
three scenes
that you have chosen to examine here i
just want to do a little bit of
overview of why you decided to make this
your i believe your seventh uh feature
film at this point uh why you decided to
do this it's a little lighter in tone
and of course a return uh to working
with bill murray
yeah i had this idea in mind um for
years now and i was trying to figure out
how to
um write the screenplay and i had this
idea that i wanted to do a
father-daughter
kind of buddy caper and and kind of an
homage to all the
great classic comedy screwball comedies
and so
i just felt like you know wanting to try
to do something
funny and lighter that also had deep
themes and i felt like just
the way just just in the these times to
have something
uh playful and fun that also tackled um
important themes to me this is your idea
of incognito
they'll never see us coming
we have supplies too hop in cutie
i noticed too it's beautiful in some
ways valentine to new york city
uh pre-pandemic when you uh shot it
it's a different new york uh and and
shooting in new york
that's almost a character in and of
itself here
yeah i always like shooting on location
i was excited to shoot in new york for
the first time and how do i
do new york and my in my style and not
feel like how we've seen it before
but i feel so lucky that we were able to
film
around new york before everything closed
down you know we had no idea we were
making a period film
yeah you couldn't shoot this in any
other city obviously and double anything
new york was very important to it i
think
yeah definitely just that we were able
to that they let us film in 21 and in
the government's bar in the carla and
all these kind of iconic
places about new york was really
important and i think adds a lot of
texture to it poker stable where you
propose to because
really well we're going to examine three
scenes and since you mentioned
21 let's start with that one which was a
scene
well all three of these are actually uh
between felix
and laura so talk about that scene and
why that was important and to shoot it
uh 21. yeah i mean that is the first
time that he kind of
was rashida's character out of her
um rut of her her life and the
responsibilities and it's the first time
he forces her to kind of to go out and
she
um and i just there's a there's the kind
of the beginning of him
uh cooking up this scheme to spy on the
husband and
um and then she you know he gets her an
ice cream sundae and he tells her a
story
about when she was a baby which is a
which was a real story
that my dad told me about remembering me
as a you know when i was a baby i
remember the first
moment the moment when i first
recognized you
as a person we were in the country
you're about nine months old and you
were sitting
on the ground and i picked you up and
your diaper was
sopping wet with mud and water and we
looked at each other
and just started laughing and
there you were i saw who you were
and here we are so i feel like there's a
lot of um
sweetness in that scene and also just
that how
you know no one else can kind of spoil
you in in your kid-like way that's nice
to revisit when you have to be a
responsible adult it's nice to slip back
to being
a kid and having your dad get you an ice
cream
hey greg could we bring the little girl
a belly buster please
i'm not worried about you kiddo you've
got brains
beauty and character which is the most
important thing a person can have
do you know what woman's that are most
beautiful between the ages of 35
and 39. great so i have
many months left women are like flowers
they're all beautiful at any age
even dried flowers you know i don't know
why women get plastic surgery
because of men like you mm-hmm i prefer
the factory original
yeah and every other bacon model
thank you i'm gonna take that as a
compliment are there two
oh scared me
you know i think everyone has a right to
their own privacy
but if he's doing something dishonorable
you need to know
and find out on your own terms so you
can be prepared for anything i don't
think there's anything at all there may
not be anything we'll find on friday
i'll pick you up we'll have some fun
no
[Laughter]
now uh another scene in new york city uh
had them going to
well he says he'll drop her off but
first they have to make a stop
and they go to this uh kind of uptown
gathering
are you felix's daughter yes i'm laura
you live in the city
i do are you married
yes i am how is it
honestly i'm not sure right now
and so she's there too meeting uh some
older people different people there at
the party talk about the importance of
this scene
in particular yeah that scene um
was sort of a felix someone he'll drop
her off oh wait first i just have to go
by and kind of
you know he's like working some deal
where he's trying to get a painting and
they're healthy to me she might make it
to 100.
all right i'll get my blood pressure up
shorty i don't like my father-in-law is
like that too we're like oh just
do one thing but we have to say hi to
the mayor on the way you know like
so it's it's kind of felix being
slippery and
and that she has to kind of go into this
exotic world that's not part of her
normal
world at this uh party at the
netherlands with this
um you know kind of uptown crowd and
then he they slip off because he wants
to show her
there's a monet painting off in a
bedroom and so he said let's walk
backwards which is belle's idea and they
they sneak out and they have this moment
where they take in this painting
together and share a moment
that's something again beautiful
i remember the first time i saw them at
the tulares
the next day your mom and i drove out to
the gardens at you honey
that is to me the trickiest thing in
doing a comedy
and then making that tonal shift and
making it work
where they do walk backwards that's kind
of the mad cap style of part of the film
but then it very much you do the shift
um flawlessly because it doesn't it just
feels so natural and it becomes a very
poignant
scene as they're looking at that
painting together and
it it's all about family and it's about
his life before that and it becomes very
poignant i think
oh thank you i was i yeah i was hoping
that
that we could go back and forth and have
those those heartfelt moments too so
thank you
the other scene you chose to examine
here is not in new york city at all but
rather in mexico where
the the movie shifts and takes a little
detour
uh to mexico and in that scene um
he's talking about his past uh
loves and particularly one of them and
um
and they have a whole conversation there
uh once again
at the table um talking to each other
talk about that scene and why that was
important that that in that particular
moment
this is the kind of one of the final
scenes between them where they
um talk about relationships and she's
looking at her marriage and trying to
understand
her parents marriage and and um
and bill when we shot that i was yeah i
was really taken
rasheed and i were both really taken
with how he really
kind of exposes himself and shows his
vulnerable side and it's another one of
those
tonal shifts because the section the
movie is is kind of the silliest
mad cap area and um and then he goes
into this
yeah this very heartfelt sincere moment
where he talks about a
past relationship and i i just remember
it was very striking
seeing him really go that uh
kind of vulnerable and deep with it
when your mom and i were first together
she was so amazing
i mean she's shown all her light on me
but when you guys came along all that
light went to youtube
and when someone looked at me again like
that
you know i wanted that glow again
you're such a baby
we all just want to be loved it's
exhausting
why it's exhausting to
try to love you enough
your mother had all these things she
wanted to do all of a sudden and all her
friends and she had you kids
you know when holly came along and was
so crazy about me
i wasn't used to it so that's all it
took
that was the appeal that she just looked
at you with such adoration
yeah and your mom didn't want to travel
with me anymore
i needed to travel she wouldn't go she
suggested i take holly
holly just started the gallery
did you know that she died this year
no she died
i never thought i'd outlive her
she was only 50.
i don't really remember her
she was funny
and very smart
and a terrifically talented painter
i never got to say goodbye to her
after everything you put us through what
it did to mom
and then you didn't even stay with holly
was it worth it
it was heartbreaking
for everyone
well it's great continued good luck with
the film as as people
begin to see it uh more and more on
apple tv and uh
and was in theaters and uh with a24 so
congratulations sophia
thank you thanks so much
you